[Music]
so
the spirit that knows spirit is
consciousness of itself
and is present to itself in objective
form
it is and is at the same time being that
is for
itself it is for itself it is the aspect
of self-consciousness and that too
in contrast to the aspect of its
consciousness
or the relating of itself to itself as
object in its consciousness there is
antithesis and in consequence the
specific character of the shape
in which it appears to itself and knows
itself
it is solely with this that we are
concerned in this treatment of religion
for we have already considered its
unembodied essence or its pure notion
but at the same time the difference of
consciousness and self-consciousness
falls within the latter
the shape of religion contains not the
existence of spirit as nature
that is free from thought nor as a
thought that is free from existence but
it is an existence that is preserved in
thinking
and also something thought that is
objectively present to it
it is in accordance with the specific
character of this shape in which spirit
knows itself that one religion is
distinguished from
another but we have at the same time to
note that the exposition of this
knowledge of itself within the framework
of this single specific character does
not in fact exhaust
the totality of an actual religion
the series of different religions which
will come to view
just as much sets forth again only the
different aspects of a single religion
and moreover of every single religion
and the ideas which seem to distinguish
one actual religion from another
occur in each one at the same time
however the difference must also be
viewed
as a difference of religion for since
spirit lives in the difference of its
consciousness and its self-consciousness
the aim of the movement is to supersede
this cardinal distinction
and to give the form of
self-consciousness to the shape
that is the object of consciousness
but this difference is not superseded
simply by the fact that the shapes
contained by self-consciousness
have within them the moment of self and
that god is thought of as
self-consciousness
the self that is thought of is not the
actual self
in order that the self like any other
more precise determination of shape
may and truth belong to this shape it
must on the one hand be positive
in the shape by the act of
self-consciousness and on the other hand
the lower determination must show itself
to be reduced to a moment
of the higher and to be comprehended by
it four
what is thought of ceases to be
something
merely thought of something alien to the
self's knowledge
only when the self has produced it and
therefore
beholds the determination of the object
as its own
consequently beholds itself in the
object
through this activity the lower
determination
has at the same time vanished for the
act
is the negative that is realized at the
expense of something else
insofar as the lower determination is
still present it is retreated into an
unessential aspect just as on the other
hand
where the lower is still dominant but
the higher is also present
the one determination devoid of self has
its place
alongside the other accordingly if the
various ideas within a particular
religion do indeed exhibit the entire
movement of its shapes
the character of each idea is determined
by the particular unity of consciousness
and self-consciousness in that religion
that is by the fact that
self-consciousness embraces
within itself the determination of the
object of consciousness
by its act has completely appropriated
it and knows it as the essential
determination
in face of the other the truth of the
belief in a determination of the
religious spirit is revealed in the fact
that the constitution of the actual
spirit
is similar to that of the shape in which
spirit
beholds itself in the religion as
for example the incarnation of god which
occurs in oriental religion has no truth
because the actual spirit of that
religion is without this reconciliation
it is inappropriate here to return from
the totality of determinations
to the individual ones and show in which
shape within the totality and its
particular religion
the others are contained in their
completeness
the higher form being placed under a
lower has lost
its significance for self-consciousness
belongs to it only superficially
and to its picture thought it is to be
considered in its proper significance
only where it is the principle of this
particular religion
and is upheld by its actual spirit
paragraph 684 is a long paragraph
there's a lot going on in there it
is also the introductory paragraph to
this entire section
natural religion show so we should
expect that there's
you know a good bit of discussion about
what natural
religion or religion oriented towards
things that are found in nature is going
to consistent
and and we do get that and in addition
to that sort of it's not at the cherry
on top but
really it's the meat that that goes
before the dessert we get these
incredibly important clarifications
about what hegel is studying
in carrying out this this
phenomenological investigation
of religion and religions
so there's a lot to be said and we're
going to go through quite a few of these
things but we should also like look at
the structure
of this section so we have this very
long paragraph in which there's a whole
bunch of things
going on we'll see how we can summary
summarize all of it
and then we have this short section and
they're all actually short sections in
this part
god is light okay so light is a natural
phenomenon it's a natural thing it's not
just that people are like oh
wow there's light or there's the sun
let's worship that
because we don't know any better we have
these very crude conceptions of things
no there's certain aspects of of these
these
natural matters that people are engaging
with that are well worth
drawing out and hegel is doing that and
then we have another very short section
plant and animal right where we're
looking at how
you know animism totemism how all these
things could could come in
and then we have the artificer spirit as
artificer and that's a bit of a
a longer section which is going to lead
us
up to the point of religion in the form
of
art right kunslich
artistic or creative religion
and so in this section hegel is leading
us into
what natural religion is going to be
remember
natural religion corresponds to
consciousness consciousness of an object
the object being things of nature
and he begins by talking about
all sorts of interesting aspects and
then saying
we're not going to be all that concerned
with these at this point but that's
where we're going
so let's talk about those he begins by
saying the spirit that knows spirit
is consciousness of itself and is
present to itself in objective form
right so spirit that knows itself that's
what we've been talking about is the
religion section
it is and is at the same time being that
is for itself so already we've got
something
put on the plate that's a little bit
different than
you know what we might expect in talking
about natural religion
especially from the last paragraph we're
dealing with spirit that is not only in
itself but is also for itself it
realizes itself
as a agent if not necessarily a subject
orienting itself
in relation to the religious object to
god the divine
so he says it is for itself it is the
aspect of self-consciousness
and that too in contrast to the aspect
of its consciousness
or of the relating of itself to itself
as object and again we see what was
talked about in two paragraphs earlier
self-consciousness which is usually
self-consciousness in relation to
another self-consciousness
is self-consciousness in relation to
itself reflexive
we also have the you know objectivity or
being present as an
object for consciousness and you could
say well where does where does religion
come in here he says
in its consciousness there is an
antithesis hegel doesn't use the the
term
antithesis here and gigan you know
because that's right
and in consequence to the specific now
here we get to
what we really want to talk about in
consequence
the specific character of the shape in
which it appears to itself
and knows itself so specific character
all right uh of shape bishtim height
der gestalt the determination the
way in which it presents itself and it's
interesting here because a gestalt is
already
stemmed right in the sense of being this
gestalt and not that gestalt this shape
not that shape or
form sometimes miller translates it as
and he he goes on and he says it's
solely with this
that we're concerned with in this
treatment of religion
and then you might say well then why the
hell did you talk about all that other
stuff leading up to it and you know
hegel is hegel he's uh gonna lead you
where he's gonna go and sometimes he
adds in some things that
strictly speaking aren't absolutely
necessary for the reader at that point
but could be helpful and
in some way gives you an idea of where
we're going with this right so
but this is where the real action is the
specific character of the shape
through which spirit appears to itself
and knows itself so this is you know
quite important this is
the four itself that we were just
talking about
and he goes on and he says
we've already considered religion's
unembodied
essence or it's pure notion that was a
couple paragraphs before
but at the same time he says the
difference of
consciousness and self-consciousness
falls within
the latter what's the latter the pure
notion right the difference between
consciousness and self-consciousness a
key theme that we've seen already
in the previous paragraphs that is going
to be
worked out as a motif over and over
again here
so he says
the shape of religion contains
not the existence of spirit as nature
that is free from thought
nor is a thought that is free from
existence so these are
what what we're not dealing with here
although these are interesting topics
right
the existence of spirit as a nature
that's free from thought
a nature that's just out there that we
could encounter
but ultimately is is you know just it's
not really spirit it's not really
geist right it's really the environment
that we
we run into nor is the thought that is
free from existence
so we don't want something that is
just abstraction we don't want something
that is pure notion
or mere notion as we saw before we don't
want
to use the example i used a few
paragraphs ago
a wikipedia article in place of actual
religious
life and conviction and history
instead what do we have he says
this is an existence a dawn sign that is
preserved
uh a haltana held on to literally
in thought or in thinking in in
you know dankin gadonka right in what we
do
as human beings we are the thinking
creature not that other creatures don't
think at all
but that's our our sort of you know
that's that's one of our best features
right uh plenty of other animals
probably think and think and
even maybe complex things they don't
think in the way that we do thinking
about thinking
writing books that all that sort of
stuff so he goes on and he says
it's it's an existence that's preserved
in thinking and here miller says and
also something thought that is
objectively present
now that objectively present to it it's
a it
is it okay of translation yeah yeah it
is
but it's not a good translation because
what does hegel actually say
he's playing off of dozen
existence and he says da zik
da ist right so the
east there is from the the the word to
to be
resign right and da
is the da in daz right so it
you know it itself is there um
it is present to itself as something
that's in front of it that or behind it
or
has some sort of location that is there
that is standing up so he says
it's in accordance with a specific
character of this shape
in which spirit knows itself now we have
to move to another thing right
the specific character of this shape
correlates
to a religion again
not all religions but a religion
and hegel is going to play off of this
you know sort of
generic or universal notion of religion
as opposed to a particular
religion a lot in this section and he
has to because
what are we doing in this entire portion
of the work
we're going through religion after
religion after religion
or type of religion after type of
religion after type of religion
not religion as such and that's what
gives us the history of religions
and that's what also gives us the
possibility of comparative
religion that we're going to talk about
here and that's what also gives us the
possibility of kind of an evolutionary
development
in consciousness of religions
so he goes on and he says that
it's in this accordance with a specific
character of this shape in which spirit
knows itself
that one religion is distinguished
from another fascinating right
divided off from distinguished works
just just as well
we have at the same time to note that
the exposition
exposition darstellum right he's going
to use the word
for stellang and we've also got
darshtelling here so
that this pudding in place you could say
making objective placing something into
existence as
what is thought what is understood right
so the the
this exposition of this knowledge of
itself
within the framework of
this single einzelmann
specific character the stem type right
each character
rather each religion has its own
not just specific character but single
individuated
einstein uh specific character specific
determinancy
right so this is an
important development
when we're looking at an actual religion
spirit knows itself in that religion
and he says that um
here we go this this uh knowledge of
itself within the framework
of this single specific character does
not exhaust the totality
of a given religion he doesn't use the
word totalitate there uses the word
gans right the whole
the the core the essence the
entirety of the religion and here's
where we should think about well what is
a religion this is going to be a bit of
a digression
um but this you know comes from years
and years of teaching religious studies
classes to
undergraduates and of talking about
religion quite a bit and doing a lot of
research on this there is no universally
agreed upon definition of religion
you will never find any any such and
anybody who prefers one to you
is either uneducated ill-informed and
ideologue or trying to get something
over on you instead what we find
is religion is an incredibly complex
human phenomena
which has historical dimensions ritual
dimensions experiential dimensions
doctrinal dimensions
you notice if you if you're hearing this
it sounds a little bit like minion
smarts
you know dimensions of religion well
that's that's one way in which we can
depict that to ourself there's all these
different as hegel's gonna call them
aspects zeitung sides to any given
religion we call them components if you
want to you can call them dimensions
and they're there anybody who says oh
religion is just
this is full of crap because religion is
never ever ever that simple it may be
that within the mind of the the thinker
who's rejecting it
uh it may be that that in the mind of
the person who has their own religion
and wants to reject other people's
religions
it may be that in the attitudes of
isolated people who don't really know
much about their religion but when you
talk about a
religion as a totality it's a
there's a lot of moving parts right it's
a complex
whole and this is the case whether we're
talking about
huge world historical missionary
religions like
christianity islam buddhism or
whether we're talking about what people
you know used to call
primitive religions now better termed
indigenous religions
even those of relatively isolated tribes
like the noscopy
way up in northern canada
complex there's a lot of things going on
there
so i'm coming back to this right there's
every religion is a totality
and he says that this darshtelling this
exposition does not exhaust
that totality
he says the series of different
religions which will come to view
just as much sets forth again only
the different aspects of a single
religion now what what the hell's he
talking about there
the series of religions like we're going
to start with these religions and then
move on to these
move on to these there's obviously some
arbitrariness to
hegel's presentation of this as we're
going to see with his dismissal
of eastern religions or as miller's
translating it
oriental you know morgan lendish
religions
uh the the religions of the lands of the
the mourning
with the east right there's some
arbitrariness to this but there's also
a really key point that he's making here
the aspects that we can find in a given
religion
we can generally find in other religions
if we're
adopting anything like a
phenomenological
attitude towards them and not the
attitude of the
the believer or polemicist who needs the
religions already to be within a
framework
and argue against them but the person
who actually wants to know what their
their religions are like who wants to
know what's going on with them who wants
to see them
as part of a way in which
human beings understand themselves in
relation to god in relation to the
the cosmos in relation to ethical life
so i'm gonna you know skip over any sort
of examples at this point but
we'll come back to that so he says that
um
here we go every single religion and the
ideas which seem to distinguish
one actual religion from another occur
in each one if we're actually paying
attention
then he says at the same time the
difference must be viewed as a
difference
of religion so how do the religions
differ from each other how can we
arrange them
not just in on the same level as all
developments of
one single thing just working it out in
different ways
but with one higher and one lower
at least in in the framework of of
spirit
he tells us that since spirit lives in
the difference of its consciousness and
its self-consciousness
the aim of the movement is to supersede
this distinction
and give the form of self-consciousness
to the shape
that is the object of consciousness so
this is a clue to what you know makes
things
the way they are in hegel's uh views on
religion right we want
self-consciousness over consciousness
and then we want a reconciliation of the
two of them
so he goes on and he says this
difference is not superseded just by the
fact that these shapes
have within them the moment of self and
god has thought of the
self-consciousness you can have that in
all sorts of religions
whether it's a religion of light or
religion of plant and animal
you can have that already he says the
self that is thought of
is not the actual self in order that the
self like any other more precise
determination of shape
may and truth belong to this shape it
must on the one hand be
posited in the shape by the act of
self-consciousness
and on the other hand the lower
determination must show itself to be
reduced to a moment to the higher
and to be comprehended by it so two two
important criteria here
there has to be a development of
subjectivity
of the self and that is
higher and these determinations must be
arranged in such a way
that the higher determinations
are superseding the lower determinations
they're putting them in a context
right rather than the lower
predominating and the higher being
muted or not fully developed or
suppressed or repressed or whatever
we're going to say
so he goes on and he says
here we go the lower determination must
show itself to be reduced to a moment of
the higher
be comprehended by it for what is
thought of ceases to be something
merely thought of something alien to the
self's knowledge
only when the self has produced it so
this is why the second
main part of the religion section is
going to be the religion of art
the object as its own consequently
beholds itself in the object
through this activity the lower
determination has
at the same time vanished for the act is
the negative that's realized at the
expense of something else
but now has it truly vanished no because
he goes on to say
in so far as the lower determination
is still present it has retreated into
an
unessential aspect so
as we're moving on getting past natural
religion
the higher determinations are the ones
the higher sides the higher
aspects are the ones that that
predominate
and the lower are just they're just kind
of there you know they may have been
part of its history but they don't
really matter
that much and so you know we could we
could think of
some of the uh examples that he's going
to use now that's
going to come about not in this section
but in in the next section
he says in so far as the lower
determination is still present right
it's it's it's a
retreated just as on the other hand
where the lower is still dominant
but the higher is also present the one
determination devoid of self
has its place alongside the other so the
lower could be dominant and it will be
dominant
in some religions and this is why
they are developmentally behind
greek religion for example so he goes on
and he gives an
example that i think we'll you know we
could talk about right
he says accordingly if the various ideas
within a particular religion do
exhibit the entire movement of its
shapes the character of each idea
is determined by the particular unity
of consciousness and self-consciousness
in that religion
that is by the fact that
self-consciousness embraces within
itself the determination
of the object of consciousness it has
come by its act
it has appropriated it and knows it is
the essential determination the face of
the
other so self-consciousness is always
involved in every religion
it's a question of how this particular
unity
of consciousness and self-consciousness
plays out
and so we've got spirit that's you know
living in the difference of
consciousness and self-consciousness and
sort of looking on
to religion as the phenomenologist who
is
you know taking in these different
religions and he goes a little bit
further and he says
this is kind of a rich sentence the
truth
of the belief in a determination of the
religious spirit
is revealed in the fact that the
constitution of the actual spirit
is similar to that of the shape in which
spirit beholds itself in the religion so
we've got religious spirit right this
sort of
abstract thing more universal and
the the constitution of it there is
similar to the shape
in which spirit beholds itself in the
religion
and then he says this for example
the incarnation of god the you know
mentioned verdin the becoming man
becoming human which occurs in
oriental religion has no truth because
the actual spirit of that religion is
without this reconciliation so you read
that and you're like
what is he referring to there i mean
first of all
what does hagel actually know about
religions outside of europe
not not actually all that much um
enough to get him enough to give him
ideas
but not enough to give him a full
comprehension
of religious systems um
certainly not at the time that he's
writing the phenomenology
so what what does he mean by
by the um
[Music]
how did miller translate it the
incarnation of god
okay well maybe that's talking about uh
avatars
in vaishnavite hinduism or maybe that's
thinking about
the conception of god in buddhism
particularly in you know uh mahayana and
vajrayana buddhism where we've got
bodhisattvas
we've got multiple buddhas at different
points in time kind of similar to the
hindu concept of the avatar
right hegel is familiar with these
things i don't think that he actually
understands them
adequately to say things judiciously
about them
but there is something really kind of
interesting in this he's using a word
reconciliation for zunung he hasn't used
that at all in this paragraph
what's going on why is he bringing that
up
there is no reconciliation
and therefore the incarnation that
occurs in these religions has no
no truth does that mean that there's
it's not an incarnation at all no
truth means something different here and
reconciliation is part of this
how consciousness and self-consciousness
are coming together for hegel he thinks
that you just don't have that
in there i think that you know quite a
few
buddhists and hindus would probably
disagree
we might also he might also be talking
about you know
the role of the immortals or the you
know celestial beings in taoism
we're not clear about who he's
referencing let's go on he says
it's inappropriate here to return from
the totality of determinations to the
individual ones
and to show in which shape within the
totality in its particular religion the
others are contained in their
completeness
the higher form being placed under a
lower
lost its significance for
self-consciousness belongs to it only
superficially
and to picture thought foreshadowing
right
it's to be considered in its proper
significance only where it's the
principle
of the particular religion and upheld by
its its
spirit so what do we have here a whole
bunch of different religions that are
going to be studied in turn
beginning with natural religions
religions that are oriented towards
natural phenomena
that are taking lower aspects as being
more essential than higher aspects now
from their own point of view
these are not lower aspects they think
that they're seizing on
what is truly essential not for
religions in general because they don't
care about that
but for our particular understanding of
who we
are and our relation to the divine
within this particular society framework
religion right and that's what's what's
happening
different aspects can be seized upon so
hegel is going to be doing something
that can you know roughly fit within the
rubric of comparative religion
but it's not comparative religion in the
sense that we might take a class in a
today
where we look across a whole bunch of
religions and we're like look at this
feature and how it plays itself out
how to sacrifice of one's
own body through mortification play
itself out
in you know monastic christianity in the
uh lakota sundance in
this phenomenon over here you know how
how do these compare with each other
hegel's not doing that
hegel is saying however there are these
aspects that
are found in various religions
it's just a question of where the
priority is being set
and we can only see higher and lower
from the perspective of some vantage
point
so hegel is presuming this higher lower
you know sort of
thing from the vantage point of what's
the ultimate religion for him
revealed religion and not just revealed
religion christianity
and not just christianity but his
interpretation
of christianity that many christians
would probably disagree with but that's
that's coming down the line
so this is preparing us to go into now
these studies very short studies of
what hegel is calling natural religion
and natural religions
you